I have Justin Timberlake Anna Kendrick
with me on zoom my first zoom interview
anyway the cool thing about talking
remotely is we get to see people's homes
and we get to kind of peer into their
quarantine lives so I know a lot of
people are playing games or doing
puzzles and all those things so I
thought that we would do a game as well
and I know how much celebrities just
love doing games on show so I thought
you and to so we're gonna do a game
called
zoom around the room here's how it goes
we will be given by my producer will be
given a word or a phrase and we will
each run to find the object that matches
that word first course I see okay I
thought Justin was stretching I thought
man he's really getting into this way
taking inventory you look like you're in
like a padded white room so good luck
finding some of the camera with the item
gets the point okay so you have to
they're gonna type in something I'm
gonna read it off I don't I don't know
either so we're just gonna go grab stuff
and then whoever's back it's important
to explain why you picked you pulled
that thing are you ready yes okay okay
so Alex why don't you give us the first
clue okay so go find something red okay
I I killed y'all I'm not gonna be fast
guys I'm not very fast I told y'all okay
wait what okay I I'm gonna try and walk
slower for you I'm in a small cabin you
know there's not many places I don't
have much red what who does like the
color red
yep I definitely had this urge to be
like
okay wait okay go ahead and explain
yours what is that this is a can of wine
hi
next time I'm quarantine with you yeah I
mean the Sun is out so what are you a
can of wine very fancy and let maybe a
nice okay so what is yours
just another this is a mixing bowl from
this morning I was talking about those
banana chocolate chip muffins okay I'm
actually in the room where I happened to
quilt and do crap so I'm a coal top so
this is a I know it's like once you have
kids it's like I'm gonna do these
motherly things and then whatever I
don't know you become weird but anyway
so I have that that's like one of the
pieces I use okay next clue
I'm killing its first point yes a fine
something from your childhood what
something from my childhood fun fact I
wore that veil as a shawl to the tiny
words when I was told you were how old
12 years old wait what wait I missed
something you went to the Tony Award at
12 years old well I was nominated did
you know at 12 years old
yes nobody told me that I did not know
that Ana thank you I know it's weird
what were you in what did you do um I
was in the Music Hall High Society which
based on the like Grace Kelly with you
so cool Wow well like sometimes I'm like
learning something new on zoom' okay
okay what did you find from your
childhood
[Laughter]
there's some old do you know the old uh
just letters where you can you're
teaching your kids spell this is this is
one that I had that we brought up here
I picked the K just for Kelly and
Kendrick this is one that's been passed
on to my guy it's the K and Timberlake
toy from your kid were like yeah this
was passed on this shows you that I'm
not willing to spend money on new toys
for my children I just passed down
spelling here's I made sure to bring
this with me because yes and they have
the new one where it came out and you
got all the games for your childhood
like on this cuz we're all around the
same age anyway I'm not gonna lie if you
played me at Mario anything I would make
you feel so bad about yourself because
I'm so excited on it rush any when I
play my husband it's sad
does that does that does that Nintendo
come with Excitebike yes it does I mean
you bought the first Nintendo it would
come with like Mario Brothers and then
young yeah duck hunt and I think
Excitebike maybe I don't know no that
was awesome
yeah anyway I love playing this while
inebriated just gonna say yes yes you
know drinking it's this let's all be
real it's happening it's happening right
now
yeah um anyway okay so this is the last
one because I'm long-winded and your
welcome team um anyway we have to find
something related to you okay oh we were
just watching trolls so this is branch
this is poppy okay can you say you love
trolls were you were you kind of worried
that mommy was gonna be a mean troll
yeah okay alright so sorry something
related to you what did you get Anna
that's awesome that's relates to you
there you go and you've got written this
was perfect that's amazing okay cool
alright well the winner is
was there a doubt it's me yeah Anna you
came in second but you know if you're
not first you're last okay thank y'all
for doing this it's entertaining to
people that are at home and don't have
anything you know to do and they're
bored and so thank you so much for just
taking the time because I know it all of
us are going through it as well so
sometimes it sucks to have to smile and
be like it's gonna be great even though
in your head
and then go back to say that
everything's gonna be great I am glad
you're safe Montana and staying healthy
just didn't say hi to your family for us
so glad you just had a birthday party
with your kid Oh Silas and and thank you
so much for coming on and looking it's
just fabulous if I'm in quarantine next
time I want you to be with me so you can
do my hair and makeup all right well I
love you guys and I'll just see you next
time maybe in person how about that love
that
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going